[Music]
did you see the trailer for the new game
of thrones
you have to
frozen give it to me i forgot you
were mine
right
i don't want to say anything i just want
you to watch it it's going to be
something don't spoil it i'm not it's
going to be so bad i'm not i will not
spoil it i don't want anyone i do not
want this to be spoiled this is
something because this actually leans
believe it or not kind of connects to
what you're saying right
um
what's it called the house of house of
dragons
sharlings is it was it game of thrones
house of gucci right that's what it was
hold on
now
before i press play
if i told you
somebody with a targaryen bloodline what
do they look like
very light blonde golden hair or like
almost white hair very pale yeah very uh
thin very usually uh slender people
light eyes uh yeah
that's all just wanted to make sure you
knew
i will just play this now
so this takes place like a thousand
years before the tv show we saw
the dream
it was clearer than a memory
and i heard the sound of her thundering
moves
i will agree by the way so far so good
wing shields are typical you know
if i placed my hair up on the iron
throne
and all the dragons roared as one
i consider the matter urgent that of
your succession
the iron throne is the most dangerous
seat in the world so far so good
is vulnerable too easily ended
who else would have a claim
the firstborn child ronero
no queen has ever sat
so let's start with number one
um this just hold on
hold on a second look at his mouth i
know that's what happened to me when i
saw it i'm not gonna lie to you i same
thing happened to me as frozen
this world is a crush hold on a second
hear me out
first off before we get into the the
obvious part what a bad wig
secondly
yes the light the light skin targets
now it gets worse okay behind front
the king has an heir damon tiger
[Laughter]
that's a targaryen yeah the north the
north uh
the north the north never forgets the
you know the the cream for their ashy
elbows did you know that
are you excited
you're excited that's the targaryen i
believe so
that can't be that can't be a targaryen
he has the targaryen crest somewhere
there
yeah
wait he might be the
oh god they literally called blackfire
in the books okay well i don't know but
they're not black guys no but these
black and did they do but what i'm
saying is is this so on the nose that
they were like how do we get some black
people on the show and they're like did
you know there's an entire group of
targaryens called the blackfyres
we just make all the blackfyres black
guys done it's already in the name
but put in the books
what happened is the king at the time
i'm a little foggy on this but had a
bastard son
this show might be actually centering
around
that story of the black fires and the
the bastard son so then like when the
king was ready to retire
his son that he had later on who's
younger but is with his actual royal
wife
uh is the next in line and then this
other guy starts like the black fires
which are parts of you know partly
targeted but they're all the same that's
that's what i've been minneapolis right
yes at the cup foods okay they're black
fires no but then
but um but they all looked the same
still they were all still targaryen like
they didn't become black guys i feel
like a lot of people say that these
people all these targaryens also look
the same
oh there's more
bulgarian
i will not be made to choose between my
brother and my
[Music]
daughter's succession will be challenged
knives will come out
[Music]
you are the king
your first duty is to take a new wife
i have the anxiety to name everywhere
this is gonna be
i can already tell you
that this is gonna be
all of that like
just bad tv writing there's gonna be
none of that oh yeah there's not gonna
be any of that george hart r martin in
this at all
because every clip is generic dialogue
from an error like a period piece in
this i shall choose a new heir and it's
like all this but you must find a wife
like it sounds like picard and the
holodeck like those quotes but but but
the other thing is like
this is like the original game of
thrones the original game of thrones
especially the tv show specifically the
cool part about the show was like
up until you didn't get dragons in magic
right away you just got a cool like you
know medieval story right there was some
magic but it wasn't like and when you
finally saw dragons like you hadn't seen
it the whole show you're like oh [ __ ]
that's a now it's just like yeah
whatever dragons everywhere magic and
elves and who gives a [ __ ] whatever hey
lord of the rings
i'm black targaryen
he's a somebody's calling it the roland
20s targaryens i don't think that that's
the name
do you think the realm will ever accept
me as that queen
the lords of the realm bend the knee
you see what i mean though about how
generic it's all just
it's all
feels like filler talk
that npcs would be saying in oblivion in
skyrim
let's um
don't forget there's some woman power in
this too
this next line
a woman would not inherit the iron
throne
what
i mean one did in the last game of
thrones series and she murdered a bunch
of women and children with her dragon so
probably a good idea that we don't have
any more women with the throne huh and
the other one with the throne [ __ ]
this is a prequel yeah so she'd be the
og
yeah but she'll probably just get up on
a dragon and start killing everybody
yeah probably a minute i'm assuming yeah
yeah because that is the order of things
when i'm queen i will create a new order
now now didn't we already do this plot
yeah yeah but this time it's different
but she's gonna break the wheel yes but
i thought there was the other one never
broken why did she just made a bigger
worst wheel why do we have to wait two
thousand years for the other one to come
along and break the wheel i'm i'm gonna
assume as well as prequels we already
know it ends badly i know you didn't
break any wheels no if anything you made
things way
[Music]
your worse has dragons
you see what i mean oh god you're right
i hate you everything is just little
snippets where you it's childlike hear
me hear me out you could recut this
trailer if somebody wants to do it if
not i get the pain in the ass but you
can recut this trailer same music
but cut out
any lines and just replace them with
skyrim lines like you were saying
earlier but actually replace them in the
trailer it would look exactly the same
and have the same feel honestly no
because skyrim had better voice acting
oh good point and uh a better story a
better story
there are power men should never have
trifled with
oh by the way every scene you saw the
dragons is all you're going to see in
the show because they have a finite
budget so what does lucha soros have to
do
which is [ __ ] that's penta
oh okay dark penta
excuse me penta scooter
guarantees the gods than to men
if rhaenyra comes into power she can cut
off any challenge to her succession
i am to inherit the iron throne
she will block my way see what i mean
it's the nothing's happening it's the
most generic clips
of dialogue i've ever heard in my life
right this is what this is what it's
like when somebody's like it's like
somebody made a fan-made trailer from
clips of a show it's like yeah it's like
a 15 year old that goes you know what i
want to learn how to like
make a show or write a show
this is the kind of dialogue they would
write because they have no world
experience and for a 15 year old you'd
be like hey man that's pretty good pal
you know you could work on a bit but
this is hbo why are we doing this even
george rr martin admits that he was just
a student of history and he basically
just took all the like the war the roses
and all the [ __ ] that happened oh that's
the one where the dj's like call people
cheating
why you messing around on this hoe and
then joe coletti gets 50 for playing one
of the people yeah i remember and
sometimes if you sometimes when you're
on a budget you just have the sales guys
down the hallway do it
oh we used to do that very specific um
the hearts remain as what oh lesbians
they're lesbians you know i don't feel
like i feel like you could probably come
up with a way more efficient lighting
system
than a thousand candles on a table
because i feel like that's a fire hazard
man you have a fireplace
have you not invented any kind of
lantern yet
do you have a spell that could make some
light
your dragons you got dragons you could
pretty much do whatever you want
[Music]
i think you're right
they heard then they took the name
literally just made them boy blackfire
that's
that makes no sense your dad cheated
with somebody who's still of the same
race
so he just had a bastard kid that
probably looks a hell of a lot in the
books if i recall correctly the brothers
actually also kind of looked like one
another right wasn't
this is very funny i hope this is the
blackfyres or just black guys that would
be the most
unintentionally racist thing you guys
have done in a long time
also royce we joked about it earlier
yeah
he was wielding a spear
uh mrm plays live says it's the king
ezekiel first of all okay it's elijah
stop all right i'm not gonna let you lie
to these people i'm not you're lying
you're lying
you are lying
um
hold on
are you saying frozen that this
targaryen is a literal
user of a spear
yes i guess he's chosen he has one
that's not a spear
okay
that's um
wouldn't know how to describe it right
now but it's more of a um
it's it's just more of a
what do you call it like when you joust
like a pole arm it's like a pole arm a
lance yeah it's like a pole arm or a
lance but it has
a blade some sort of spear-like blade
i see what you're saying
but yeah it's more of a lance they have
um
ones that they used to have some people
had ones that had like [ __ ] literal
blades on them could just [ __ ] you up
yeah but the black targaryens hold them
sideways
have you never imagined yourself
if you whisper the dialogue is my
poignant i learned this
from a young walk in phoenix that's
right because that's all he used to do
now give me my goddamn oscar
the iron throne
he's you know game of thrones asmr is
terrible how long do you think this one
lasts this the show
they sunk money i'll tell you you're
gonna give it frozen tell me the budget
they'll give tell me the budgets
well it's the other thing is it's like
it's based off of a lot less material
you know what i mean like it's off of an
offshoot it's not based off of like six
books you know
true
so
[Music]
uh under 20 million per episode
under 20 million per epi that means 20
they gave him a 20 million dollar cap is
what that means
per episode
he's [ __ ] crazy he's really counting
on that game of thrones reboot holy [ __ ]
dude and instead they're just doing more
of
the the end game [ __ ] they did last time
that everyone hated so i don't think
this is going to go over very well game
of thrones
end game
so about 200 million we gotta have a
game of thrones civil war first oh
you're right you're right that's fair
enough i like that
that's uh we have to have a game of
thrones age of ultron and then game of
thrones infinity wars yeah the infinity
war is a good one
where is judy
where is sacrifice
oh they see you as you are it's poignant
again because they're whispering
uh i have to give credits
it really does
um and to give credit to house somatic
uh so does the new black targaryen from
uh house of the dragon clip the ears of
his dragons
okay that's not that's [ __ ]
really brutal
that's very funny
that is very funny uh instagram pictures
of like uh who's they say dragons are
evil oh proud dragon mom and then it
attacks a kid oh my god do you think
they have like dragon fights
yeah of course they do uh who's the mike
vick of destroying entire cities yeah
way more people die than dragons yep
question
yes
do i put the first two episodes on the
list
i i i don't i don't know if i can make
it through two episodes how two episodes
one up each episode's an hour right
yeah one episode normally our rifts are
like that an hour thirty two yeah i get
it i get it one episode um i'm not doing
two but i'll do the first one
so i take it you're not excited there's
so they're spending up to 20 million
dollars an episode mm-hmm
this show
just i've never heard
of anyone on this show
yeah no well matt smith uh you know you
know matt smith because he's uh
he was one he was on doctor who he's one
of the doctors uh didn't watch doctor
who no i know but i'm saying that that's
a no name i don't know the only guy i
recognize from this from this show from
the cast
is the guy that played the saint of
killers in preacher
oh yeah he was really good in that